في حدث اليوم القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه
في واشنطن ما الذي تنتظره الاداره
الامريكيه من القاره السمراء سعيد بان
يكون معي من مدينه دمبر الامريكيه ابراهيم
ادريس وهو باحث في شؤون الافريقيه اهلا
وسهلا بك ودائما في نفس المكان ودائما في
نفس الاستعداد للاجابه على الاسئله سؤال
الاول هل يريد بعيدا اصلاح ما افسده ترامب
اهلا بك
حقيقه
وديموقراطيين تحديدا خرجوا بمشروع جديد
يختلف كليه حتى عن سياسات الديمقراطيه
السابقه لتجاوز الازمه التي خلقها همم
الرئيس السابق
واللي همم حصل بسببه همم فيديو كبيره في
العلاقه الامريكيه
طيب اوكي ولكن الان عندما نرى بان الرهان
هو رهان جيوستراتيجي من قبل الاداره
الامريكيه هل هذا يعني هو خوف من الامتداد
الصيني
والامتداد الروسي في القاره السمراء
[موسيقى]
الكم الضخم للاستثمارات الصينيه هي الهاجس
الاساسي
الشيوخ للاداره الامريكيه
للمؤسسات الاساسيه زي وزاره الدفاع
الاقتصاد المال كلها هؤلاء مجتمعين
منزعجين تماما من الدور الصيني واتجاوب
الافريقي اللي برز في انهم بداوا يتحالفوا
مع الصين والدخول روسيا في الخطب بعد همم
ازمه همم اوكرانيا همم كل هذا تجمع لانه
السياسه الامريكيه يجب ان تعيد
مجالها كما الفرنسيه والادراك دخلوا في
افريقيا واصبح هناك دور الامريكي هو دور
يلحق الاخرين وليس مكانا كما كان في
السابق تاريخيا يقود الاخرين طيب نقطه
الاختلاف الان هو ان هناك سياسه عند
عدم التواجد عسكريا في اكثر من منطقه بين
ذلك فيها افغانستان وفي اماكن اخرى في حين
ان
الانقلابات والمشاكل ازدادت في القاره
الافريقيه اذا العديد من الدول هي في حاجه
الى دعم عسكري بدرجه الاولى
في اللحظه اللي هما بيرفضوا فيها وجود
الاخرين هم يمارسوا الدول بشكل اخر
ودخول همم افركوم ازعل كثير من الدول
الافريقيه التي اصرت على انها تبحث عن
البدائل بدل هذه الهيمنه العسكريه ان يكون
هناك همم علاقات اقتصاديه هي التي تقود
امريكا فتنت لهذا الموقف الان بتحاول
بجانب انه مصر على افريقيا تستمر في
سياستها الا انها قدمت برامج جديده
اقتصاديه على مستوى محاور متعدده في
المساله الزراعه التكنولوجيا الطاقه
البديله
الزراعه والتنميه المستدامه والبرامج اللي
انا تابعتها من الامس واليوم في الحلقات
اللقاءات اكدت انه حتى الافارقه متنبهين
لكن ايضا الافارقه بداوا يعني يستثمر هذه
المساله لصالحه وبرز اكثر في انه في هذه
همم
الافارقه البدو رواه وبرامجه الاساسيه في
التعاون ونقد التجربه السابقه التي همم
بالفعل قد نرى لها ايجابيات جديده من
السياسه الامريكيه التي تاخرت في افريقيا
وهي طبعا السياسه الامريكيه بالنسبه
لافريقيا متاخره تماما عندما نرى عدد
اللقاءات الصينيه الافريقيه وعدد الريقات
الروسيه الافريقيه ونراناها القمه الثانيه
بعد القمه التي نظمها اوباما يعني فكرت
بشكل متاخر في هذه العمليه او عمليه
التقارب على الاقل من لقاره السمراء
امريكا اخطات ايضا حتى في برامج
الاقتصاديه انها بدات تمارس بها شكل من
الضغط اين في الصراع اللي تم في القرن
الافريقي انهم حجبوا عن دوله اثيوبيا اغول
اللي هو البرنامج الاقتصادي اللي بيدعم
الاقتصاد المحلي
والبرايف الساكتر واداء في حد ذاته النقدي
اللي تجربته عليه
الامريكان يجب ان يصححه موقفهم تجاه
القضايا الفعليه في ما تخص التنميه
افريقيا محتاجه تنميه افريقيا في حاله
بتاعه ازدهار وانهارده همم يعني دخول
الجنوب افريقيا نيجيريا رواندا التجارب
الموجوده الان بين النيجر وبنين وكل هذه
الحقائق تؤكد للامريكان بان افريقيا اصبحت
تبحث عن البدايه من يقدم شروط مناسب هو
اللي هيكون له قبول فليست السياده لامريكا
ولا للروس ولا الصينيين ما لم تتفق مع
سياسات الافريقيه الجديده اللي بتقود
الاتحاد الافريقي واللي بتقودها هذه
التكتلات في غرب افريقيا وشرق افريقيا وسط
افريقيا فيما يخص السوق الافريقيه
المشتركه النهار ده الجزائر بدات تمثل رقم
اساسي في السياسه الاقتصاديه في اوروبا
لانه الغاز اصبح
الطاقه البديله ايضا هتكون موجوده المغرب
عنده يعني طاقه في
السولار باور مذهوله كل هذه المسائل بدات
تنبه لها اوروبا والغرب والشرق عليه همم
افريقيا همم
اقتصاديا اقدر اقول انها بدات تفرض
برامجها والامريكانو لاخطائهم الفراغ
الموجودين فيهم والانتخابات الاخيره
التصوير الاخيره اللي تم في الامم المتحده
ازعج كليه السياسه الامريكيه الحاليه طيب
وهذا لانه افريقيا بان الولايات المتحده
تريد ان تستخدمها ورقه دبلوماسيه هي بحاجه
لصوت لكل بلد عندما تحتاج لتنفيذ سياسه
معينه ولكن بالنسبه للوضع الان في
اوكرانيا الوضع مختلف لان لافارقه يعني
يترددون كثيرا في الوقوف الى هذا الجانب
او ذاك
ليس
[موسيقى]
رؤيتك سليمه جدا واضيف لها حقيقتين
الحقيقه الاولى انه
الافارقه بداوا النهارده كمثال اصبحوا
ينتجوا الزرعه بكميات ضخمه همم
الفكره بتاعه التنسيق مع ال ال
الروس او اصبحت واضحه همم قضايا عمليه في
العلاقات الصينيه ليست همم فارق الضغط فقط
بعد اجتماع همم الرئيس الصيني في الصين في
السعوديه اكد على انه حتى موضوع الطاقه
حتى تكون موضوع حساس وافريق عندها طاقه
همم بتروليه هائله
والغاز موجود في شمال افريقيا كل هذه
العناصر همم بلا ادنى شك تجعل الامريكان
في موقف همم مهزوز موقف ضعيف موقف يفرض
عليهم انه يدعو لهذا الاجتماع ويكون ايضا
متوامين
وقضيه مساله الضغط بالله بالله بالتهديدات
السياسيه يجب ان تخف يجب انه يتعاملوا مع
هذه الدول بشكل مشترك في قضايا النزاعات
الموجوده في افريقيا وكثيره لم نقعد نسمع
في افريقيا عاده كنا نسمع سابقا مثلا
نعطيك سبيل المثال في الازمه الليبيه حتى
حتى من هو ليبي يقول لك في حال تدخل اعمل
الولايات المتحده يمكن ان نتوصل الى حلفه
اكثر من قضيه واكثر من ازمه وكاني بهذا
ال- بهذا الدور الامريكي قد تبعثر دور
الدوله التي يمكن ان يكون لها نفود تباثر
في القاره الافريقيه
وده
عنصره الاساسي يمكن القذافي
انت ليبيا القذافي هو اللقاء في مبادره
اعاده تكوين الاتحاد الافريقي الاتحاد
الافريقي النهارده عنده اليه متقدمه جدا
في فضل النزاعات رائع اين ذلك في قضيه
كثير من المواقف راينا من افريقيا يصبح
احد عندك صوت واضح اتجاه الانقلابات في
افريقيا هناك مؤسسه بدات يعني الزرعها
تكون عمليه وتنفيذيه في افريقيا عليه همم
امريكا وغير امريكا والامم المتحده تحديدا
لهذه الخطوه الكثير من الدول او حتى الدول
الحلفاء للغرب اكدوا عنه الدول الافريقيه
يجب ان يحترم ويقدر هو ده اللي جعل بين
النهار ده يطرح قضيتين اولا الموضوع همم
المجموعه 20 انه افريقي تمثل الدول
المشتركه عبر الاتحاد الافريقي دي خطوه
متقدمه ايضا هنسمع بكره احتمال همم قنبله
اتجاه قضيه همم موضوع
انه الامم المتحده في مجلس الامن الافريقي
يكون عندها صوت وامريكا بدات تنحاز همم
نسبيا او تلعب على هذا الوتر
كل ده اكيد انه المقوله انت قلتها فيه
تجربه الليبيه انه لا امريكا ما هياش
الاساس هناك حلول افريقيه
بايادي افريقيا هناك دور الجزائر بدا بشكل
متقدم جدا في كثير من النزاعات راينا جنوب
افريقيا تمارس ترفع عال جدا في نزاعات
الافريقيه كل هذه المؤشرات التي الاداره
الامريكيه تفتطن لانه افريقيا ليست
افريقيا
جديده وهناك رؤيه جديده وهناك همم نفس يجب
ان نتعامل معه الغرب بيكون له مستوياته
والصين تنبهات والرؤوس التنبه لهذه
المساله وافريقيا تريد ترويج بضائها في
الولايات المتحده وهذا هو الاشكال الكبير
اقوى مشروع تاريخي حينتهي سنه 1025 احتمال
يتم تجديده هناك نجوتين حول اجواء اللي هو
المشروع الاقتصادي اللي بيدعم السوق
المنتجات الافريقيه تدخل الى
الى امريكا وراينا انهم عنده النهارده
وقعوا بين بنين وامريكا والنيجر اتفاقيه
طويل جدا تدعم نفس هذا الموقف اللي احنا
نتحدث عنه الان
تدريس ابراهيم ادريس شكرا جزيلا لك
شكرا استاذ توفيق